madame la présidente madame la première
ministre chers collègues le 19 juin
l'histoire retiendra qu'il sait pas
c'est un événement majeur un
bouleversement démocratique une
évolution salvatrice des pratiques
institutionnelles
ce 19 juin à 20 heures
l'histoire retiendra que les français
ont imposé l'equilibre
peut-être pour avoir trop abusé des
prérogatives que lui confiait la
constitution pour les avoir certainement
trop mal utilisé pour avoir cru que du
palais de l'elysée il était possible
d'imposer aux français les volonté
unilatérale d'un seul sans les écouter
sans les concertée sans les considérer
emmanuel macron qui avait tous les
pouvoirs se voit aujourd'hui qu'on
craint donc tendre les français et c'est
heureux
le peuple a suivi en cela les
recommandations que nous exprimions avec
sobriété je le crois ça cesse lors de la
campagne des législatives et a décidé de
ne pas lui abandonné tous les pouvoirs
il lui impose aujourd'hui à rééquilibrer
institutionnelle puisque nous sommes
passés d'un régime très présidentiel à
un régime plus parlementaire c'est le
retour du politique qui lui saute au
visage c'est un grand moment politique
le peuple malicieux a répondu à son
appel de venir le chercher et avec les
rames que lui offre la démocratie l'a
remis à sa place
qu'a dit le peuple vous êtes le
président et l'on vous donne certes une
majorité me une majorité relative nous
voulons vous obliger à ne pas gouverner
seul nous voulons vous obliger à
entendre les oppositions à prendre en
compte des préoccupations qui vous
aurait échappé à diriger autrement sans
brutalité sans provocation pourtant le
président on fait comme s'il ne s'était
rien passé
en chemise manches retroussées échevelé
par l'action il se met en scène en
sauveur du monde comme si l'exercice du
pouvoir devait se réduire à une
bande-annonce netflix à la divulgation
irresponsable
table de discussions diplomatiques à
quelques facéties immature et dérisoire
d'un pouvoir irrémédiablement
narcissique
mais surtout
mais surtout dans la vraie vie il nous
afflige des remaniements plus
improbables les uns que les autres sur
la forme des remaniements distillé par
bribes annoncé par la rumeur au goutte à
goutte comme un robinet qui fuit en
oubliant qu'une autorité gouvernementale
si nécessaire aux pays se construit par
le sérieux et la solennité se
crédibilise par la vision et la
cohérence
la situation gouvernementale n'est pas
sous contrôle mais comme tant d'autres
comme dans tant d'autres domaines pardon
or contrôler les nominations
invraisemblable se succèdent sans tenir
compte des élections sans tenir compte
de la volonté collective qui s'est
exprimé sans tenir compte du changement
institutionnel qui est intervenu le
pouvoir ne réfléchit plus il tâtonne ils
ne décident plus ils improvisent il
n'agit plus il titube la seule certitude
qui lui reste c'est l'illusion de la
puissance
emmanuel macron n'a pas compris que le
premier ministre ne devait pas dépendre
de la seule volonté jupitérienne mais
devaient s'accorder avec l'assemblée
telles qu'elles ressortaient des
élections le temps où il était à la fois
président premier ministre ministre de
tout est révolu ce n'est pas vous faire
injure madame bornes que de dire que
compte tenu des circonstances
électorales votre nomination ne relève
pas d'une décision de grandes politiques
mais un scénario devenu obsolète cette
confirmation dans vos fonctions au
lendemain des législatives ne relève pas
du réalisme politique ni même juste
compréhension de la nouvelle donne
démocratique mais presque d'une
incongruité institutionnels et je dirais
d'une provocation politique c'est un
soin caf à emmanuel macron et on envoie
immédiatement les limites puisque madame
la première ministre vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans l'impossibilité de
solliciter un vote de confiance et j'ose
dire que vous avez bien fait car nous
n'avons aucune confiance dans votre
gouvernement
alors ce n'est pas illégal mais c'est la
normale est surtout révélateur du
caractère bancal de l'édifice
institutionnel qui tentent
laborieusement de se dresser devant nous
le président n'a pas compris
l'injonction nouvelle qui lui était
faite de prendre du recul de s'effacer
devant la volonté du peuple et de
n'avoir pour seul devoir que de la
mettre en oeuvre le pays voulait
davantage de sécurité il reconduit eric
dupond moretti il s'inquiétait du
malaise dans la police et constater le
désastre du stade de france et il
confirme gérald darmanin y constate
l'effondrement de l'hôpital et notamment
des services d'urgence il nomme françois
braun qui suggère comme réponse de les
fermer la nuit il réclamait il réclamait
de la sincérité
et se donne comme porte parole
olivier ferrand
il attendait de la cohérence et voilà
très courageuse sarah lahiri
contrebalancer symboliquement
l'invraisemblable nomination du voc east
pap ndiaye le pays voulait de la retenue
et il invente un ministère du plein
emploi comme on sortirait du chapeau un
ministre du bonheur ce qui ressort de
tout cela malheureusement pour le pays
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de direction la
direction ces deux éléments d'abord la
maîtrise des événements emmanuel macron
et son gouvernement ne gouverne pas mais
rafistole deuxièmement le sens donné à
l'action là où on attend une vision on
ne constate que des contradictions on ne
dirige pas un pays dans la disruption
obsessionnel et dans le en même temps
pathologique
gouverner
c'est voir la situation telle qu'elle
est comment maîtriser des événements
qu'on est incapable de voir gouverner
c'est donner un cap gouverner c'est se
donner les moyens humains et
institutionnels de l'atteindre ce que
souhaite le pays c est redirigé une
vision politique claire qui donne à
l'autorité publique un sens et assigne à
l'action publique des objectifs clairs
et accessibles
le pays va à vau l'eau une violence
endémique qui s'enkystent partout il
submersion migratoire que le pouvoir ne
sait même plus de juguler un sentiment
d'abandon notamment des plus vulnérables
qui se généraliser avec lui
l'appréciation de l'avenir qui gagne une
inflation provoqué par cinq ans de
gestion calamiteuse qui menace les
paniers annonce la ruine des
travailleurs modestes des classes
moyennes et des retraités
le litre d'essence à 2 euros 30 le
travail qui ne paie plus une
organisation ferroviaire qui avec les
premiers effets de la privatisation des
rails des pénuries qui s'installe
partout un effacement total de la france
sur la scène internationale et notamment
sur nos terres traditionnelles
d'influencé comme l'afrique il est temps
de remettre la france en ordre il nous
faut retrouver une parole publique dont
la crédibilité a soir à l'autorité il
nous faut reconstruire l'état son
autorité ses moyens il nous faut
redonner au pays un projet collectif
enthousiasmant
ces grands objectifs corollaire
indispensable du redressement national
le groupe du rassemblement national les
peurs à valoir ici il défendra les
grandes priorités que ses électeurs lui
ont donné pour mission de promouvoir et
dans toute la mesure du possible de
faire appliquer retrouvé notre
souveraineté en se préservant d'une
union européenne prisonnière d'une
dérive impériale qui constitue la
négation du droit des peuples et des
gens renouer avec une représentation
politique ou sociale vraiment
démocratique qui fasse que chaque
citoyen se sente représentée
revoir l'action diplomatique
sécuritaires sociales judiciaires
éducative
repenser le modèle économique mondialisé
pour un modèle basé sur le localisme les
circuits courts et la promotion des
productions locales et nationales bref
un modèle plus vertueux plus écologique
plus responsables se pencher sur les
conditions concrètes de vie des français
leur pouvoir d'achat leur santé leur
logement leur droit à la mobilité à la
liberté ouvrir des perspectives pour les
trente années qui viennent par la
redéfinition d'une grande politique
industrielle la mise en oeuvre de choix
énergétiques prospective dégager de
stupide a priori idéologiques de
rééquilibrage du territoire et la
recherche d'une plus grande harmonie
économique par une politique de des
métropoles isation en faveur de la
ruralité
nous mesurons la responsabilité que nous
ont confié les électeurs en nous plaçant
comme premier groupe d'opposition cette
désignation comme force d'opposition de
gouvernement
c'est à dire comme force d'alternance au
pouvoir en place nous honore évidemment
vous l'avez compris nous ne souhaitons
pas être une position d'obstruction mais
de proposition pas une position de
principe qui chercheraient à mettre le
pouvoir à la faute mais une force qui
place l'intérêt national au dessus des
veines et venimeuses agitation partisane
sur les principes qui sont les nôtres
vous nous trouverez toujours ferme selon
l'attitude du gouvernement réseau lui
soit à nouveau posée si les mesures vont
dans le mauvais sens soit à trouver des
voies de passage dès lors qu'ils en sont
pris en compte cela signifie par dans la
prise en considération de nos priorités
de nos motions et de nos amendements il
appartient donc au gouvernement de
décider du blocage ou du fonctionnement
institutionnel
si charlie adam excusez-moi j'ai quinze
minutes a failli être un autre
intervenant de ses débuts qui n'a l'air
bien de toi moi sinon ça ne passait que
l'intransigeance leur union en paroles
ou l'irrespect envers nos électeurs il
en assumera devant le pays la
responsabilité pour notre part nous
sommes prêts à toute éventualité
nous n'aurons pas à voter sur la
confiance puisque le gouvernement se
dérobe et nous influeront donc sur les
textes qui nous seront présentés au
premier rang desquels celui que les
français attendent avec espoir et
impatience celui sur le pouvoir d'achat
notre première décision a d'ailleurs
légitimement été de demander une
commission d' enquête sur les raisons de
l'inflation qui les frappe madame bonne
vous ne pourrez pas faire comme si de
rien n'était vous ne pourrez pas faire
comme si rien n'avait changé le peuple a
voté
entendez le nous sommes ses
représentants entendez nous
[Applaudissements]